congratulations on uh on this film my
friend where did you film all the uh the
outside stuff for this movie because it
looked gorgeous
thank you yeah we shot the whole film in
new zealand um you know top to bottom
that that's where we shot so gorgeous
place gorgeous country
uh incredible people it was it was a
fantastic place to shoot
how flattered are you that um
you know people really consider you to
be a prince my friend
like you know like you've got that
stature that princely stature and it's
good to see you carry that on in this
thank you thank you man yeah i'm
ecstatic you know i woke up this morning
uh with the news that the film is top 10
on netflix in
many many countries across the world
including the us and canada so
um you know i'm ecstatic that people are
watching it it's a lighthearted
family film which i think we all need a
little bit more of uh nowadays and and
to start off 2022.
it is really a lot of fun watching you
and laura together in this film did you
have a lot of time together before you
started filming or was it sort of like a
jump right in and let's get this
chemistry going scenario
um you know a little bit of both it was
mostly virtual believe it or not just
because uh the first two weeks in new
zealand was locked down quarantine and
uh the quarantine in new zealand was
uh you know was government quarantine so
we were both in two different hotels you
know didn't get to see each other didn't
even get to meet
until after uh the quarantine process
was over in new zealand but we did a lot
of
virtual one-on-ones uh rehearsals you
know getting to know each other
and
her and her mom and her sister produced
this film so i had conversations with
them prior as well
what's really cool too about this is it
takes that idea of like
you know uh this girl meets the prince
as like so many of those types of movies
do but kind of flips on his head too in
the way that she affects his life right
yeah a lot of this is flipped on its
head um
you know
in a lot of different ways even just the
class structure of both prince thomas
and izzy it's kind of reversed um izzy
is this girl from new york but she's
kind of the one on the on the lower end
of the class structure if you will and
he's a prince from a far away country um
but i like that i like that you know in
in a genre that's done so much and so
often we were able to kind of find the
little different things that we could do
to set it apart
there's something that you do in this
and i've noticed you do this
in other films i've seen too this this
look that you have that you're very good
at which is like this love struck thing
you do the love struck thing really well
like you're stunned and shocked by this
person like what is what are you
thinking about
when it's when it's time to have that
sort of close-up are you thinking about
the person are you thinking about a
particular meal you love like what's
going through your head
um
you know it depends it depends on a lot
of stuff but uh a good acting coach of
mine once told me
um and from toronto actually but he told
me
um always try to find something that you
find beautiful about the other person so
it might be their eyebrows it could be
their nose it could be anything but just
find something that you uh find lovely
about them so
i still remember that to this day but i
also try to find the beauty in everybody
and everything that i work with so
uh that that definitely helps i love
that
rate in mind on from one to ten okay
i watched yours last night and i was
like i gotta i gotta get this down like
how'd he do it
okay i'm gonna stay i mean let's see it
let's see but i'm gonna stare you right
in the eyes okay
all right
is that any good i don't know it's
pretty good less headshaking less
headshaking the eyes are there
but it's good it's good you're almost
there
that's what it is
um so
we talked a little bit about how this
movie kind of flips the conventions of
some rom-coms on his head do you have
like a top three romantic comedies that
you love to go back to when you just
want to feel good and feel the love in
the world
yeah i do i mean so a lot of people
probably wouldn't consider it um
a romantic comedy per se but i'd say
it's a family comedy dramedy but there's
so many aspects of it that just you know
tear you apart you laugh you cry uh you
know mrs doubtfire has always been
uh one of those top movies for me that i
go back and watch often just because of
what robin williams is able to do in
that film
um silver linings playbook is one of my
favorite uh romantic comedies you know
obviously with the great jennifer
lawrence
um and bradley cooper
and um i loved la la land when it came
out too i thought that was really cool
maybe the musical aspect of it
and ryan gosling's just very charming so
uh you know i'd say you know those are
three of the ones that that i love to go
back and watch yeah you've been having
some i mean anyone that follows you on
instagram knows all the cool stuff
you've been doing all the great
adventures that you've been having one
of them i want to talk to you about
though is walking in rihanna's show
is being a part of the savage fenty show
like
dude like what was that like that seemed
so out of this world to me what was it
like
um it was pretty insane you know it was
it was quick it was i think two days of
shooting or maybe one day of rehearsals
and one day of shooting but
um you know i always try to find stuff
that gets me out of my comfort zone and
do something a little bit different
and this was definitely a little bit out
of my comfort zone i've always wanted to
walk the runway because i love fashion i
love going to fashion shows
uh but to get to do it on rihanna's show
on amazon was
uh you know it was a dream come true so
it was it was really cool man it was
very very cool and definitely put me out
of my comfort zone
yeah that's awesome um you know the last
time that we had a chance to be together
obviously at a moment i'll never forget
we were together
singing in a helicopter one of my
favorite things
ever ever
um uh for a role that was an amazing one
for you and i want to know do you think
that you'll have an opportunity to
revisit that role is there anything on
the horizon that you think man i could
do that that one again
i hope so man um you know i know they're
just trying to get it right on paper
uh with the script and the story and
everything uh you know a lot of people
don't know this but the producers of
aladdin are also the producers of the it
franchise the lego movie franchise it's
two popes
they do some incredible incredible work
but
they always want to make sure that they
get it right i think you can see that
from the films that they produce
um over at rideback
dan lynn and jonathan irick so
um they're working on it man they're
working on it they want it to happen as
much as we all do you know me naomi and
will
uh we want to all do it again you know
i've spoken to them everybody wants to
do it you know everybody wants to do it
again we had such a good time um it was
such a good film for for families all
around the world so
we want to do it and they're working on
it but um how far away they are from
kind of getting it right i have no idea
right on well dude it's so good to see
you congratulations on the success
congratulations on this film thank you
so much for the
small acting lesson
[Laughter]
you got it carlos i used to watch you
when i was a kid man on my tv so you
taught me a lot of what i know too bro
the back it just was this back in the
day it was more this
that was my look back
i don't know if that would fly for a
rom-com hey it worked it worked
good to see you man hope to see you
again sometime soon i'll get out there
one of these days
thank you very much carlos be well man